how you doing i'm good how are you look
at this setup you got going
it's a bit of a vibe i mean i'm in i'm
in los angeles i mean i'm chilling
there a little pipe there you go see him
right yeah i mean
when the time so you were brilliant in
this
i mean you're always brilliant in
everything but this was like
super incredible do you pay attention to
reviews when things are getting like
award season buzz or do you not want to
read it at all
somebody someone said something really
interesting on the weekend they said if
you pour your heart this is a musician
he said if you pour your heart
into something for two years and like
your heart and your soul and your
everything
like you're not not going to read it
because it's your feelings however you
can
he was just saying that that person
isn't qualified
to define who i am
and define what how i gave and what i
gave in my heart you know i'm saying so
i probably i haven't read them i'll
probably will and you can always feel it
you can feel the energy like you came in
the phone cause yo
the reviews the reviews ain't great you
ain't going to say that you go like oh
this film that you did
like so you can feel like when it's when
it's good energy and it's good vibes
and you just kind of like and it's
always nice that if it's a good vibe
when you start doing interviews because
everyone wants speaking it from about it
in a positive way
it allows you to kind of speak deeper
into the film because it actually is
accessed the person that like someone
like you speaking
speaking about yeah um fred was
incredible
at speaking in front of a huge group of
people he was so good at it
preparing for this role how did you
prepare to do that are you already good
in front of a large crowd were you in
the mirror
practicing i want to know these things i
was not in the mirror practice
at all what i was doing you know it's um
i've done
because i've done a number of plays back
in london so that
kind of and i spend i remember there was
one play where i did
um a monologue like i did six months
actually
was when i did a monologue and i was
skipping and boxing at the same time
in the round so i had to kind of skip
and move around and speak to everyone
and like project and do my voice
so that kind of i knew i could just
saying i knew
i knew i've been able to do i've done
monologues in past like even coming up
and acting i've done monologues
in order to to grow my abilities so i
knew
i i had that um i had that ability and
i've done the hours in that sense and so
yeah and i kind of but i think be doing
it as fred
the chairman fred it was a kind of um
was something that i was like
oh that's a whole different get the fix
because you're embodying someone's
spirit you know
your body in a real person that people
can go on youtube and
and look at and and compare and this is
the other
so it was for me it was just like i
would watch clips
and see how his spirit moved me and i
was like oh my north stars i want to
move
people the way he moved me yeah because
if you shoot your spirit the shape
follows
you know saying so it's like it's like
that it's kind of like i go
if i'm reaching for that essence and
that that vibe and be a vessel for that
then hopefully all the other decisions
and then i can't make any other
decisions i have to make that one you
know and and that was my north star
with black history month we want to
celebrate black excellence
so i have to ask you is there anybody in
entertainment
that has affected you either just for
your career and your personal life that
you would
you know want to honor for black history
month denzel washer
yeah i mean like if you really really
sit down there and really take in
what he did in in the 80s and the 90s in
the early it's it's
iron is like like i feel like for me i
can't have the career i have
at this current moment 10 years ago and
he had that career
but he had a career that he owned for
himself
and it's like it's is i mean to and he
you
you put him in the same breath as tom
hanks and leonardo dicaprio but
he was a black man yeah jason doing this
and like standing up john zayn and like
leading things and
leading things like on black narratives
that was defined by
his spirit and his perspective not
necessarily how white people perceive
him
mm-hmm that's a real that's a that's
that's something that the majority of
people are learning how to do now he was
already doing that i mean it was his
career and his decisions and his
intentions are incredible
it's like it blows my mind and on top of
that he's one of the best actors that
ever lived
you know so me and denzel washer i love
that
thank you i appreciate your time king
such great work
thank you take care bye
you